[music]
What's up y'all? I'm back today with
another reaction video. This time from
an Adventist pastor who runs the YouTube
channel Kenhorst SDA Church who put out
a response video titled The Reason
former Adventist answering Adventism is
constantly attacking the SDA church,
which no, theological critique is not
attacking. If that's the case, the SDA
church is the biggest attacker of
Christianity in the world. But
nevertheless, let's hear his hypothesis.
Okay. I mean, he points out three
different reasons for leaving the
Adventist church. And I will say these
three reasons are among the strongest
ones, the reasons why I am a Seven Day
Adventist. Um, Ellen White, h
interpreting the Bible through the lens
of Ellen White. I I think that's a
strange view. Uh, let me hear it again
because you said that 7 interpret the
Bible through the lens of Ellen White.
Um,
I don't think so, buddy. I don't know
where you get that from.
Uh, your own organization's primary
source documents. One of the regular
sources we site around here, the June
3rd, 1971 Review and Herald, long after
the 1919 Bible Conference. Folks,
Protestants have always claimed that the
Bible is its own interpreter. Perhaps it
is better to say the spirit of prophecy.
We use the term here as synonymously
with the gift of prophecy or testimony
of Jesus is its own interpreter. The
Bible is an infallible guide, but it
needs to be infallibly interpreted to
avoid confusion and division. And again,
the official statement of confidence in
the writings of LG White, which is
literally on the SDA church's own
website for anyone to access. This is
put out by the GC, folks. We reaffirm
our conviction that her writings are
divinely inspired, truly Christc
centered, and Bible-based. Rather than
replacing the Bible, they uplift the
normative character of scripture and
correct inaccurate interpretations of it
derived from tradition, human reason,
personal experience, and modern culture.
And yet again, GI Butler, former General
Conference president, folks, what did he
say? Our position on the testimonies is
like the keystone to the arch. Take that
out and there's no logical stopping
place till all the special truths of the
message are gone. Our enemies and the
master they serve realize this. But some
of our people are so blind that they do
not. So I guess this SDA pastor fits the
bill for one that is so blinded he can't
see the fact that without Ellen White,
Adventism collapses. So yes, I'm sorry
you aren't aware of this, James. I'm
glad that I could help you out, but this
isn't some hidden or secret thing. I
didn't make this up like so many SDAs
try and postulate. Ellen White is the
interpretive guide to scripture in
Adventism. And it's why around here you
will see us use a picture of her with
the papal tiara photoshopped on her head
to make the point because we have done
multi-hour presentations on this exact
subject numerous times showing far more
than just those three citations. I
really wish people like this would do
more homework than watching a single
7-inute video and then do this sort of
wild wild west approach of of
gunslinging a response. The video he's
responding to was literally the first
video I ever made. It was before the
answering Adventism website was put
together and this channel was even up
and running fully. It was a simple like
icebreaker video to kick things off that
almost functioned like a testimonial
video. It was short, simple, to the
point, simply telling people that may
have come across the channel why I left
Adventism. I figured that would be a
common thing people would be asking from
the get-go. And I get it. This video,
for some reason, YouTube has picked it
up and still promotes it like crazy. So,
he probably chose that because of that,
but he clearly hasn't bothered to look
into anything exhaustive that this
platform has put out. anyone that's been
writing with us for any length of time
just heard him say that and knew exactly
the sources that we were going to be
looking at. So yet again, we have an
Adventist pastor who is unaware of these
things. But yes, James, this is a
strange view. Like you mentioned, which
is why it's in part why I left the SDA
church. Yet you said the reasons I gave
for leaving are why you are an
Adventist. [clears throat]
You sound confused, my friend. And this
is the problem. You get Adventists who
will b and scoff at what I say, yet they
themselves aren't even keyed in on the
primary source documents. They think
their own personal opinions and beliefs
are the standard for the organization
when they aren't. This platform is about
the SDA organization, not your own
personal beliefs, your own personal
opinion. Shoot, if that were the case,
this organization would look
schizophrenic because we'd be all over
the place because Adventists are all
over the place. But no, he hasn't
brushed up on the SDA system of theology
as a whole to see how foundational this
is Ellen White to the entire SDA
framework. Uh because one of the reasons
why this claim is not true because Ellen
White did not invent
or write or wrote a single doctrine for
the Adventist church.
Uh where was that claimed again? Had
[clears throat] this gentleman bothered
to even do a cursory investigation into
answering Adventism, he would have seen
this on our website. On an article
titled, "Who was Ellen G. White?" I
write, "She did not originate any
doctrines of the Adventist Church, but
functioned as the movement's prophetist
who served as the stamp of approval from
God when it came to the correct
interpretations
of scripture." And yes, as you can see,
stamp of approval is hyperl and will
take you right to the source that this
is being pulled from. I never claimed in
that video or in any of the hours and
hours of content that we've put out that
Ellen White originated any SDA doctrine.
This is you just assuming things. I'm on
record both on here and on numerous
other podcasts that I've been invited to
speak on stating exactly what's in that
article clarifying for people unfamiliar
with Adventism that she didn't originate
any SDA doctrines but functioned as the
conduit messenger and stamp of approval
from God. Do not use these arguments,
please, when engaging with Roman
Catholics.
It will set up any seasoned Roman
Catholic apologist to jump off the top
rope and flying elbow that level of
apologetic through the ring and bury it.
Adventist, when you say this, Roman
Catholics immediately are going to
dismiss anything else that you have to
say because they're going to know you
didn't even bother to learn what they
actually believe. It would be the
equivalent of when someone says Ellen
White originated all of SDA teaching.
Adventists will immediately just dismiss
anything else someone has to say because
they know she didn't originate any of
the teaching but supposedly received
vision confirming the beliefs that they
say were arrived at through deep
biblical study. That's the belief and
claim. Hence why I said the reason is
she is the interpretive authority not
the doctrinal originator.
So if Ellen White did not write any of
them where did they come from? Well, the
pioneers of the church
studied the pioneers of the church had
already they were coming from different
denominations with biblical knowledge on
many basic things. You can say there
were other pillars of the advent
teachings that were added such as the
Sabbath, the sanctuary, state of the
dead, spirit of prophecy, and so on. But
they're not in contradiction to
scripture because these things can be
clearly defended from the word of God
without the use of Ellen White. This is
not to say I don't believe in spirit of
prophecy. I do believe and I preach and
teach and encourage people to read the
book the spirit of prophecy.
Yeah, you can arrive at all these things
from the Bible alone except GI Butler
just told us that if you remove Ellen,
all the special truths of Adventism go
with it. Again, James, had you bothered
to even do a cintillaa of digging, you
would have seen, I already know
everything you just said. You're simply
paring all the same talking points that
SDAs do. It's so tiring. It's
exhausting. It's hard to take seriously.
These are things I already know. None of
what you said refutes that Ellen White
is the infallible interpreter in
Adventist theology proper. We looked at
sources that clearly you're unaware of,
yet you said that's not what's taught.
Okay. In the article I just showed, I
note exactly what you just said. I
literally hyperlink to the exact quote
you're referring to. The pioneers would
be studying and come to a crossroads and
Ellen would then supposedly be given a
vision and be shown the correct
interpretation. And yes, she did give
the stamp of approval on false
interpretations. You claimed that
everything she gave the stamp of
approval on can be defended from
scripture. Adventists love saying this.
And what they mean by this is that they
can point to a proof text and then
assert, see, it's biblical, which only
begs the question, you assume Ellen
White's interpretation is correct, but
don't demonstrate it. No, you can't
demonstrate from scripture that Jesus
was inaugurated to be a high priest at
his ascension because that contradicts
the Bible. Jesus was inaugurated as a
high priest at his baptism when the
anointing of the Holy Spirit, the true
oil, was poured out on him and the
blessings spoken over him by his father.
He gave up his high priestly prayer in
John 17 as a high priest. The law
required that the day of atonement
sacrifice be offered up by who? The high
priest. Jesus functioned as both the
high priest and the offering at Calvary.
This doesn't even get into all the
blunders regarding the the daily
ministration of the priests where she
claimed that during the daily
ministration on behalf of penitent
Israelites, the priest would sacrifice
the animal brought by the Israelite,
then take the blood and transfer the
sins in type into the sanctuary and
sprinkle the blood before the veil for
the sins of the people uh to rest in the
sanctuary or the sins of the penitent
individual to rest into the sanctuary.
until the day of atonement. No, this is
false. According to Leviticus 4, the
priest during the daily administration
only took the blood into the sanctuary
and sprinkled it before the veil on two
occasions. When the priest sinned and
when the entire congregation of the
Israelite community sinned
unintentionally.
Never for individual penitent
Israelites. And this causes your guys'
entire typology to break down. And
that's not even scratching the surface.
She claimed to be shown in vision that
the holy kiss that Paul signed off with
in the epistles was to be a normative
ordinance for the Christian church that
the antichrist had caused to fall away.
It was a work of antichrist. She claimed
that the holy kiss wasn't being
practiced as a normative ordinance for
the church and needed restored along
with footwashing. Yet later in the
youth's instructor and the review and
herald, two official SDA publications,
they admit that there's no evidence that
the holy kiss was to be normatively
practiced, but was simply a cultural
custom, which means that they
essentially call themselves Antichrist.
I could go on and on and on like we have
on our website in other videos. Her
stamp of approval from God contradicts
the scriptures constantly. Well, if you
don't want to read them, you don't want
to read them, fine. You can read the
Bible. The Bible is more than enough.
But if you're looking for a magnifying
glass, you want to go deeper in your
understanding of scripture, I will
encourage you to read the spirit of
prophecy because it does magnify the
Bible. So, so that first argument here
is kind of it's kind of weak and I'm not
necessarily understanding what were some
of the reasons why uh because of that
having been born in the church. He says
I don't know how you came to this
conclusion as an individual. Uh, I came
to that conclusion based on the primary
source documentation of the organization
like we just saw and have looked at in
depth in multi-hour breakdowns and
walkthroughs that you're clearly not
aware of. But he said the Bible is
enough. Yet, as we saw earlier, the
sources you are apparently ignorant of,
we can't understand the Bible without
Ellen White's interpretive guidance.
Without that, we will supposedly be left
in division and confusion according to
your organization's official source
documents. This is supposed to be the
hallmark of you guys being the remnant.
That unlike all those Babylonian
Protestants out there that are all
doctrinally confused, Adventism is a
bastion of unity. We have no doctrinal
division. We've got the God particle,
the theory, the theory of everything
according to Herb Douglas. In fact,
apparently this SDA pastor isn't even
aware of the Adventist Believe
Fundamental Beliefs book, which utilizes
Uriah Smith's analogy for Ellen White in
the Bible, which is found in the Review
and Herald, which we've looked at
before. Notice one illustration may help
to set this matter in a still clearer
light. Suppose we are about to start
upon a voyage. The owner of the vessel
gives us a book of directions telling us
that it contains instructions sufficient
for our whole journey. and that if we
will heed them, we shall reach in safety
our port of destination. Setting sail,
we open our book to learn its contents.
We find that its author lays down
general principles to govern us in our
voyage and instructs us as far as
practicable touching the various
contingencies that may arise till the
end. But he also tells us that latter
part of our journey will be especially
peril that the features of the coast are
ever changing by reason of quicksands
and tempest. But for this part of the
journey he says I have provided you a
pilot who will meet you and give you
such directions as the surrounding
circumstances and dangers
[clears throat] may require. And to him
you must give heed. With these
directions, we roach the perilous times
specified, and the pilot, according to
promise, appears. But some of the crew,
as he offers his services, rise up
against him. We have the original book
of directions, say they, and that is
enough for us. We stand upon that and
that alone. We want nothing of you. Who
now heed that original book of
directions? those who reject the pilot
aka Ellen White or those who receive him
as that book instructs them. Judge ye.
So no, we can't just read the Bible
according to the SDA church. We need
your prophetus. Otherwise, we'll be left
in confusion and not be able to
understand the Bible properly. And this
doesn't even get into the mountain of
statements from Ellen herself that we've
looked at I don't even know how many
times in detail where she claims that
her writings are underappreciated and
underread which leaves people
susceptible to deception. That if you
reject her writings you insult the
spirit of God. You will eventually
reject the Bible outright and end up in
predition and countless other claims.
No, her writings are not just a
magnifying glass that you can and cannot
utilize if you so choose. Either this
guy is severely ignorant or he is lying.
All he's demonstrated thus far is that I
was correct in the video that he's
responding to and he hasn't done his
homework on the organization that he is
a salesman for.
For me is like I wasn't raised in it. So
I've I've come in and able to appreciate
it. I've also noticed something there's
a pattern that I've noticed um among
people who were once Adventist who
leaves the faith and now speaking
against the Adventist church. often time
they were raised in the advent faith. So
most people were raised in the Adventist
faith either didn't take it seriously,
they didn't practice what they were
taught or they were live they're either
in a home who knows what was going on in
that home, what was the condition of the
home, right? So they turn out to be the
worst enemies of the Adventist faith.
Often time it's not an advent issue.
Sometime it is something spiritual.
Sometime it is there is some type
emotional
uh instability. There's something going
on in the life but often time these
things you don't see. I think there's
something else going on behind some of
these arguments. It's not really an
Adventist thing from my perspective and
I'm I'm of course I'm speculating of
course but I can pick up on behind that.
There's a lot of things being said here
that are not true.
Yeah, you are most circul certainly
speculating. Um because what you're
saying is just it's like hard to even
take serious folks. It just after you've
heard this five million times. I left
Adventism over a decade ago. I've heard
this I don't know how many times. It
just it doesn't deal with anything. We
just looked at primary source documents.
He comes back saying, "I've never heard
this." Uh you know what I find with a
lot of these former avenists it's all
emotional reasons.
Gotcha. No, we got the classic. It's
because of the SDA home they were raised
in. Folks, I I tell you guys this all
the time. This is one of their favorite
lowbrow, lowhanging fruit arguments. The
sort of idea that former Adventists had
an abusive upbringing regarding
Adventism. Ellen White shoved down their
throat. It's like, not only is this
silly, but it doesn't deal with the
substance of what's presented. It's
like, okay, now that you got that out of
your system because you just had to
viscerally respond with that, let's deal
with uh the substance of what was
actually presented. How's about that?
This is a sideeshow argument because
they are ignorant of the facts like we
just saw and it makes them feel better.
Nothing about my upbringing was abusive.
I've talked about this a number of times
as well. I was raised in like a super
basic milktoast SDA household. Probably
no different than a lot of other kids
outside of Adventism, aside from, you
know, the unique components of going to
church on Saturday and and those sorts
of things. But most Adventists, or maybe
I shouldn't say most, but a good number
of Adventists would condemn my SDA
pastor dad to predition because he's one
of these evangelical hybridized SDAs
that's inconsistent with the SDA system
as a whole. And I don't say that to
disparrage him, but just to say I didn't
grow up in an oppressive SDA household.
Besides, my personal upbringing has zero
bearing on objective truth. I care about
the truth, not my own personal
experience. Or, well, my family is this,
so that's irrelevant to facts. I mean,
Mormons could say that same thing. All
these arguments SDAs use, it's like you
can always port this over to like, well,
Jehovah's Witnesses must be true
because, oh man, there's smart people
that are that are Jehovah's Witnesses.
Um, there's people that have left and
speak out against Jehovah's Witnesses
because they were raised in it and came
to find out it was a deception. Oh, no,
they're just hater. It's like all this
stuff could literally be ported over to
like any other false sect out there.
Adventists use this argument because
they can't actually engage with what's
presented. So they speculate and bring
up things that are entirely irrelevant.
He said, "Oftent times it's not an
Adventist issue." Yeah, James, you
evidence you are just speaking off the
cuff, making a response that does
nothing to engage with answering
Adventism. Our website and content
present hundreds
hundreds of highbrow theological
arguments. Nothing about personal
feelings or upbringing. Again, had you
even bothered to do 10 minutes of
digging into the platform, you would
have seen this. You are literally
responding to a video that gives three
simple reasons that are theological for
why I left. And instead, you claim it
was because of emotions.
This silly claim doesn't hold water for
anyone who's done even a cursory level
of investigation into the material that
I've presented. And this video wasn't
even all of the reasons. Again, it was a
simple icebreaker video for the YouTube
channel. Not exhaustive, not overly
in-depth, just a simple introduction for
people to me. Maybe instead of assuming
that those of us that were raised and
educated in the SDA church are just
crybab who got caught in our feelings,
you should consider that we've actually
done a more in-depth understanding of uh
or or a more in-depth deep dive on the
understanding of the SDA system as a
whole, and we studied our way out of it.
Crazy I know but just a thought.
So there is something he calls Adventist
faith believe in a different Jesus.
Is that what he said? Let me play that.
Glee. However, the Jesus of Advent. So I
do not say this with glee. However, the
Jesus of Adventism is a different Jesus
than the historic biblical Christ.
I only hear that from Adventist critics
because having been in the Adventist
faith for such a long time uh over well
it's only been I'll say 14 years now
I've been in Adventist schools um hung
out with Adventist pastors read the
books um taught teach and preach on the
pulp at aventist churches I have never
heard such a thing like I only hear it
from people online I don't know how they
came to that conclusion his argument is
that um they have any stretch belief in
classic uh uh tri theism. I I didn't
even know what that was. So, um
well, maybe that's why you're confused,
dude.
All you appeal to is personal anecdotes.
And so, because you haven't heard it or
you've only had this, that means there
this is such like lowbrow level
engagement, James. We have hours and
hours and hours and hours and hours of
content on this specific subject because
it's one of the central things that's
wrong with Adventism, not some tertiary
issue. I could bring up all sorts of
issues, folks, that I don't bring up
because they're not foundational. It
doesn't put Adventism outside of
orthodoxy. And when I do critique
something that I believe is not in line
with scripture, but it's a secondary
issue, I clarify that. But that's why
you're confused and it sounds like a
personal problem. I know lots of people
outside of the SDA church that recognize
the Adventist Jesus is a false Christ.
Many of them engage with our content and
have been on this platform. There's
entire books written by people who were
never SDAs that did a deep dive study on
this and came to the same conclusions.
But furthermore, how is that relevant to
the point? The core issue with Adventism
is the great controversy worldview
which defines all of Adventist thought
and theology including christologology.
This is part of why answering Adventism
exists. I get it. This guy couldn't be
bothered to do any sort of homework. But
part of why we exist is to help
Christians better understand the
theological dangers of Adventism by
helping piece together here's what they
mean by these terms. Because again, I'm
always talking about you have to scale
the language barrier. Adventists use all
of the same language as Christians, but
they mean entirely different things.
It's like he's appealing to I've been
around other Adventist pastors and well,
no duh, dude. You're not going to hear
it from them. Like, obviously.
It's like you don't even know how I came
to that conclusion because you're not
familiar with the primary source
documents. It's like, are you really
trying to act like the great controversy
theme doesn't inform all of Adventist
thought and theology? Again, we've
looked at the sources on that. Herbert
Douglas Ministry magazine, December
2000. Go look it up. But in that system,
the Adventist Jesus was exalted to be
made equal with God the Father prior to
the creation of the earth. That's
damnable heresy. was only a man on earth
who set his divine nature aside that he
received through exaltation and was only
a man on earth which is called the kosis
heresy. He ceased to exist for 3 days in
the tomb. He doubted his resurrection
and if his sacrifice would be accepted
because Satan was able to twist his mind
causing him to doubt which is a sin
because doubt is unbelief and unbelief
is a sin. It would mean that Jesus
didn't have perfect faith, which gets
into something else I've talked about I
don't know how many times. You have to
have Jesus's perfect passive and active
obedience to be able to be seen as
righteous. If Jesus didn't have perfect
unwavering faith, you can't have Jesus's
perfect passive obedience imputed to
you. This is a serious blundering issue.
Yet when you bring it up, Adventists are
like, "Well, it says on the cross that
uh why did the father forsake him?"
That doesn't say that Jesus doubted his
resurrection or if his sacrifice would
be accepted. This is again bringing
Ellen White to the text, citing a proof
text, and then because you can cite a
proof text, well, see, it's biblical.
No. And that doesn't even get into the
countless other christoologgical
heresies that you would have been aware
of had you even bothered to do a
fraction of digging. And yeah, it makes
perfect sense that those who have left
Adventism would be better informed on
SDA theology and recognize the false
Jesus of Adventism
than those outside who never had a great
controversy worldview, don't understand
the way that the language is being used,
and focus on other areas of expertise.
The reason this guy is confused and
doesn't understand my reasons for
leaving Adventism is because sadly he's
deceived. He isn't even aware of these
primary sources that we've shown on this
subject in large quantities. Anyone
that's been writing with us for the past
year is more informed on primary SDA
source documentation than this guy who's
an Adventist pastor. And it's also
interesting that he says he only hears
this from former Adventist and that he's
an outsider that wasn't raised in the
movement, yet he's just paritting all
the same tired assertions, talking
points, and objections that any former
Adventist has heard a million times.
Like, dude, do you not think I've heard
all this? It just That's why I'm saying
it's hard to even take this seriously.
It's like for the 10 millionth time, we
get to hear the same stuff pared back to
us. Yeah, we've heard all this. We've
heard all this. It shows you haven't
done as much research into this as you
think you have. It's like I really wish
folks would these these folks would stop
to think that maybe just maybe we've
heard all this before. I heard all this
my whole life. Long before I even left
Adventism, long before you made this
video. Long before I started answering
Adventism. It's like we're former
adventists, man. We know all of this
stuff. That's why I call it the script.
And
what was the other thing? The atonement
continues. Well, that's it's not a new
argument. Like to say that the atonement
continues after the cross. That makes
you
that makes you believe in a different
Christ. It's kind of like I mean if you
study the sanctuary it's only common
sense that there is there is a
progression to salvation also. Um so
there is the justification
sanctification and glorification. So
there is something that Jesus is doing
in heaven. He's our heavenly high
priest. He is interceding on our behalf.
We can come boldly to the throne of
grace that we may obtain mercy and find
grace to help in times of need. He has
entered by his own blood into the holies
of holies to minister for the children
of God. So if you're hearing a lot of
noise up there is because the children
are home and they're having a lot of
fun. So that's just what it is. I never
said it was a new argument. I said it
was a part of why I left Adventism. But
no, it isn't common sense if you study
the sanctuary. It's hilarious to me that
SDAs will say this. Yet, no one until
the 19th century due to multiple failed
prophecies arrived at this conclusion.
It's just it's just common sense. Yeah.
No one before them had common sense.
This is why I'm always saying you need
to understand, folks, like the implicit
statements that Adventists make without
even realizing it. You're basically
saying everyone was dumb until we came
along. We're here to correct everyone.
It's just common sense. Yet, we know
that no one before us understood this or
saw this, but it's a present truth
message that we're here to uh to to
share with you. Yeah, give me a break.
It's just common sense, but it took a
fringe group of of fanatics in the 19th
century to see it. And God was
supposedly using deceptive means to lead
them to understanding it. It's common
sense. Yet, they didn't they don't even
believe the same thing about it um in
the 21st century that they did in the
19th century. It's common sense, but
it's a special present truth message
that only Adventists have. A small sect
that makes up less than 1% of the global
population, but is supposedly God's true
people arbitrarily starting in the 19th
century because, well, they up and
deemed everyone else to be apostate. But
yes, James, it is a part of why you guys
have a false Christ. Because when you
use the word atonement as we've looked
in salvation contours of Adventist
otiology which is put out by your
church's own scholars supposed to be
this new staple work on Adventist
otiology you guys mean investigative
judgment when you use atonement. So you
have a Jesus who is still uh dealing
with sin, standing wearing Levitical
priesthood garments, functioning like a
Levitical priest in a building in heaven
that is at war with one of his creatures
and is working on vindicating the
character of God, but is getting
absolutely obliterated in the great
controversy. Satan is totally rocking
his world and on and on and on. This is
evidence, folks, that many SDAs live in
a shoe box of a universe. Because it's
only by living in that isolated reality
that you could say what he said and not
see how out of touch it is. No, the
sanctuary doctrine isn't simply the idea
that there's a progression of salvation.
This is the classic Adventist juke of
boiling things down to vague
generalities and then bing and scoffing
as if it's those who take issue with the
convoluted idea who are in the wrong.
95% of Adventists can't even explain the
seven steps of the sanctuary to you.
Just ask them. Next time you encounter
an Adventist, say, "Hey, can you explain
the seven steps through the sanctuary to
me?" Something Ellen White said, "If you
don't understand, you won't have the
faith necessary to be saved." And then
watch them short circuit before your
eyes. Watch. 95% of Adventists can't
even explain it to you. Notice he said,
"There's something Jesus is doing in
heaven. He's our great high priest. So
that automatically means the SDA view of
the sanctuary is true. I I mean, what a
joke. This is insight into how SDA's
assume that they're the only ones that
think Jesus is a high priest and
everyone else thinks he's twiddling his
thumbs in in heaven.
No, James. The point is Jesus isn't
dealing with sin anymore. That's not
what his work of mediation entails. You
guys don't understand that he is a
prophet, priest, and king. All of which
is simultaneous.
This is another area where your
prophetist contradicted the Bible. She
claims that he'll cease being a high
priest in the future. This is in the ear
in early writings. She saw this in
vision, the vision where she saw him get
up off the throne and move from the holy
place into the most holy place. He's
going to take off his priestly garments
at at a point in the future. He will
assume the role of a king at that point
and cease being a high priest despite
Hebrews 7 a plain thus sayaeth the Lord
which is citing from the Old Testament
which foretold that Jesus Christ would
be a priest forever
forever. And it's by virtue of what does
the author say in Hebrews 7? His
indestructible life.
You guys don't teach this. You guys have
an entirely different system going on
there. But see, you're not getting into
any of these finer specifics. You're
doing like SDA scholarship does. You're
using general Christian terms and then
saying, "Well, how could people take
umbrage with this?" Well, yeah, you're
not even getting into any of the
specifics. And it shows you guys don't
understand the priestly role of Christ
as well as you think you do. Yet, you
think it's Christians that are ignorant
on this subject. Now, I'm not going to
get into all of that as our website and
other videos have exhaustively done
this. So, for the sake of brevity, you
can go check that out. We have an entire
playlist dedicated to the Adventist
Jesus. But I think this clearly shows
why he is confused regarding my
reasoning. And Adventist nine times out
of 10 don't actually know what other
people believe. They didn't resurrect
the idea of Jesus being a high priest.
That's just what it is. Um anyway,
so that's not even a good argument
either. So I've addressed this with
what's his name? Jim Babber. He seems
like a lot of former former Adventists
are among the worst enemies of the
Adventist faith. And that's very common.
That's very normal, right?
Jim Bab isn't a former Adventist James.
[music]
He talks about this all the time. He I
mean, seriously.
But yeah, no duh, dude. Former
Adventists care about Adventists and
want them to know the truth and not be
deceived and end up in predition.
I I I don't understand why SDAs are so
surprised by this.
Yet, they're a part of a movement that
is obsessed with pointing out the errors
of everyone else and seeking to warn
them to come join the remnant or they're
going to be damned. Yet, when you turn
that around and say the same thing back
to them, they play victim, act like
you're a hater, etc. I I said it before
and I'll say it again. If it wasn't for
inconsistent standards, many Adventists
would have none.
So the third one, the Sabbath is the
seal of God. He argued that the Sabbath
is not the seal of God and that uh
central to their entire movement is
their belief that the seventh day
Sabbath is the seal of God and that
yeah actually it is is the seal of the
living God. I did explain it because you
go to church on Sabbath or you even keep
the Sabbath doesn't automatically
gives you the seal because there needs
to be relationship with Christ as well.
But I've explained it a little bit
deeper in my study of the seal of God. I
think is study number seven uh oh number
six where I spoke about how the Sabbath
is the seal of God and how you need to
carefully study uh the commandments of
God and the idea of the law of God
written in our hearts the name of God in
our foreheads in connection to the seal
and the signs and the glory of God and
so on. When you make all the
connections, you connect all the dots,
you'll come to the conclusion that the
seven-day Sabbath is the seal of God.
And in the seventh day Sabbath or the
three elements that compose a seal, we
have the name, title, and territory,
which God created the heavens and the
earth and the sea. So there's no other
commandments that have these very
serious and good elements to establish
God's authority and power over his
creative work. So
again, we get the it's just obvious. you
just you have to study more carefully.
Ah, so no one else was studying
carefully until the SDAs came along.
Again, another one of these unspoken
implicit claims that they're making. But
once again, I I nowhere claimed that
just because you go to church on
Saturday means you automatically have
this alleged seal. Again, had you even
bothered to listen more before doing
this response, you would have heard that
we've looked at Ellen White's claim that
many SDAs won't receive this alleged
seal. But notice Testimonies for the
Church Volume 5, a few pages of before
where we looked earlier. Quote, "Jesus
is the only true pattern. Everyone must
now search the Bible for himself upon
his knees before God with the humble
teachable heart of a child if he would
know what the Lord requires of him."
However high any minister may have stood
in the favor of God, if he neglects to
follow out the light given him to God if
he refuses to be taught as a little
child, he will go into darkness and
satanic delusions and will lead others
in the same path. Not one of us will
ever receive the seal of God while our
characters have one spot or stain on
them. It is left with us to remedy the
defects in our characters to cleanse the
soul temple of every defilement. then
the latter rain will fall upon us as the
early rain fell upon the disciples on
the day of Pentecost. Close quote. So
the SDA church teaches model man
theology that Jesus was the great
example that you're to look to for a
pattern and you're to perfectly model
that to be rewarded with eternal life.
So, she's talking in this chapter about
SDAs and says that many SDAs who keep
the Sabbath won't even be given the seal
of God because they didn't actually walk
out the perfect obedience modeled by
Jesus and get their characters
completely free from any defects, aka
sin. And it's only when enough
Adventists get to this point that the
latter reign will fall, which they
believe is a period right before the
time of trouble and the close of
probation. [laughter]
I'm aware of all of this. I know, James.
How is that relevant to my point? It
isn't. You agreed. You guys teach the
Sabbath is the seal of God. No, it
isn't. And no amount of mental
gymnastics, inference, assumption, and
hopscotch exesus will change this. You
literally just pared all the same
talking points the SDA church has been
making for 170 years, my guy. It's like
you're even paring the three elements of
a seal, like the presidential seal
argument. You're just paring RF Katrrol,
Joseph Bates. You're just paritting
these people, which is an anacronistic
reading of the text back into it
something from the modern day. Which is
funny because Adventists will tell you
they're all about a plain thus sayeth
the Lord. Yet nothing in scripture
plainly says a seal has three parts. And
so therefore, the fourth commandment is
the seal of God's law.
Yeah, that's a fact. Uh is the Holy
Spirit the seal of God? No, he's not the
seal of God, but he is definitely the
agent that God uses to apply the seal.
He writes the law in the heart. Uh the
Holy Spirit, the third person of the
Godhead. You can say he does the
sealing, but he himself is not the seal.
Oh, he isn't. Notice this plain thus
sayeth the Lord, folks. No anacronistic
analogies like the presidential seal.
just plain language. In him we have
obtained an inheritance, having been
predestined according to the purpose of
him who works all things according to
the counsel of his will, so that we who
were the first to hope in Christ might
be to the praise of his glory. in him.
You also, when you heard the word of
truth, the gospel of your salvation, and
believed in him, were sealed with the
promised Holy Spirit, who is the
guarantee of our inheritance until we
acquire possession of it to the praise
of his glory. Sealed with James. Do you
know what with means? It means the Holy
Spirit is the seal. Ephesians 4:30 says
he also does the ceiling. It is a both
and, not an eitheror. And if you think
this is obscure and can't be easily
understood, then you have zero business
claiming anything in the Bible can be.
This is so remedial and simple that even
a newly born, you know, newly born again
believer who's on milk can understand
this. And this is the proof that you
guys are committed to your tradition,
not the truth. Because this is as plain
as the nose on your face. Yet you guys
will say the Holy Spirit isn't the seal
and that we need to do all sorts of
crazy hopscotching all over the Bible to
try and make the fourth commandment the
seal of God because your guys's entire
system depends on it. And you just
proved my point in the video.
Ironically, this is why I left
Adventism. You guys make the clear
passages obscure and think the obscure
passages are crystal clear. It is an
entirely backward hermeneutic. Once a
person hears the word of truth, the
gospel of their salvation, and believes
on the Lord Jesus Christ, the Holy
Spirit uses that and moves upon a
person, regenerates them, and seals them
unto the day of redemption. The Holy
Spirit is a down payment from God of the
inheritance that one has in Christ. It's
like the earnest money on a house. It
guarantees from God that people will
acquire what God has promised in full.
This is very simple. Yet, because
Adventism does not understand the
gospel, you guys obscure this glorious
truth. So, thank you for proving my
reason for leaving Adventism to be
sound. Um, the Sabbath is the seal. It
has to be something that is stamped on
the character and that happens to be the
change of heart that happens as a result
of living a life in accordance with the
will of God by grace through faith. So
that's not anything that's strange.
No. See, you guys don't understand the
new birth. The new birth is a change in
one's being and nature, not just
character modification. We've gone over
this, I don't know how many times. You
can try and change your character and be
a moral and upstanding person all day
long and never see the kingdom of God.
But because you guys don't understand
the true nature of man, [snorts] that
man is born dead in sins and trespasses,
like Paul goes on to say in literally
the next chapter, Ephesians 2, and needs
to be made alive by being united to
Christ and their spirit being raised to
life. You guys are essentially preaching
a version of moral therapeutic deism.
It's also interesting that you talk
about the law of God being written on
the heart, but you guys always ignore
Jeremiah and the author of Hebrews
literal next point that when this
happens, God remembers a person's sins
no more. That's part of the promise of
the new covenant, which again entirely
destroys the sanctuary doctrine that you
told us earlier is just obvious in
scripture. God doesn't remember our sins
anymore because he writes the law upon
our hearts. We leave off that uh that
that that part about the sins not being
remembered anymore cuz well they're
stored on record in heaven to be
investigated. [snorts]
So he ended the video by saying well he
started the video by saying the same
thing.
So you could really boil it down to one
answer really. I left the Seventh Day
Adventist Church because I became a
Christian.
And I asked the question, well you were
never a Christian to begin with. If you
had to leave the seven adventist church
to become a Christian, well, there was
something wrong with that Christianity.
Because is the seven adventist church
responsible for your Christian
condition? In part, yeah. But largely,
if you have a Bible in hands and you
have some knees, you can bow down and
you have a desire to obey the Lord. It
doesn't matter what denomination you in,
you can have a relationship with Jesus
Christ. But the doctrine does matter. Um
don't get me gonna don't get it twisted
because the doctrine does point you to
Christ. It does point you to the truth
and that's very significant. So there
are a lot of people who are not
adventists who are Christians, you know.
So there are a lot of people who
who are in the Adventist faith at all
Christians and I don't think you have to
leave the denomination in order for you
to become a Christian. I mean you can
become a Christian uh regardless of
where you are. So being part of a
denomination has a lot to do with the
truth that is being preached in that
denomination and the fellowship that you
have with the people of God and the
mission of the church. And if a person
doesn't feel like the Adventist church
teaching aligns more with their belief
system, I think you should leave and go
find somewhere where you feel like you
can better fit.
James, you missed the point,
unfortunately. And I wish you I wish it
would have clicked, but let me break it
down for you. Very simple. When I said I
left the SDA church because I became a
Christian, I meant that the 7th Day
Adventist Church isn't Christian.
Seventh Day Adventism is not Christian.
That's why this platform exists.
Not that I wasn't a genuine Adventist.
And no, once again, we got more of the
personal beliefs being passed off as
official SDA teaching. Like, do these
people even look into who they're
responding to or criticizing? No. Yet
they'll Adventists will come at me that
watch this channel. They'll come at me
from this channel telling me I don't do
a comprehensive enough dig. I'm not
exhaustive enough. I don't understand
Adventism. Yet then they'll go comment
on videos like this and be like, "Yeah,
you really showed him." It's just so
pathetic, man. So pathetic.
No, you can't be in any denomination
according to the SDA. According to
official SDA teaching, I'm supposedly an
apostate Babylonian and God's wrath is
kindled toward me. You guys are the
remnant, the apple of God's eyes.
Supposedly, all of us are doctrinally
confused and intermingled with Roman
Catholicism. Allegedly, it's like he
mentioned the mission of the SDA church.
James, the entire mission of the SDA
church is to preach your guys' novel
gospel that you claim is in Revelation
14. That's not actually there. But part
of that claim is that it entails calling
people out of their current
denominations to join you all, the
remnant. And after hearing this, a
person is now responsible to join you
guys or they'll be damned. We've looked
at this numerous times, folks. It's
literally on the SDA church's website.
Like again, for the sake of brevity, you
can go check that out in the other
videos. I I I mean, it's just
it like I don't even know what to say.
It's like either this guy is lying or
he's ignorant. No other options. But
this also goes back to reason two in the
video. No, Adventism has a false Christ
and a false gospel. James, the Jesus of
Adventism is not real. Just like the
Mormon Jesus, Jehovah's Witness Jesus,
the Unity Jesus, Muslim Jesus, and
countless other false Christs that are
not real. 2 Corinthians 11, Matthew 24,
etc. Make it clear there are false
Christs in the world. Some Adventists
have this very watered down idea. Well,
because we use the term Jesus. That
doesn't mean anything. Who are you
talking about? It doesn't work that way.
You can't just use the name Jesus and
say, "Well, we have the correct Jesus
cuz well, we believe in Jesus."
No. It's like many of them also tend to
think that since they know every sign
and symbol of the Bible and what it what
they represent, that'll save them. I'll
be good to go because I have this
special insight that no one else has
because, you know, we're the only ones
that really understand prophecy. That's
another one of these areas that
supposedly it was all just a closed book
and and and no one really knew anything
about end times or esquetology, you
know, before the SDA church came along
because that's part of their mission is
they think God raised them up as this
prophetic voice at the end of time to
really show people what's going on in
the end of time. Yet at the same time,
they believe in a false Christ that's
not real and a gospel that can't save
because it's a false cursed gospel
according to Galatians 1. But thinking
you know about the T horns and what they
represent in Daniel. Yeah, that that's
apparently more important. It's like
this is just further reinforcing why I
left Adventism. You can believe in a
false god that cannot save you on your
way to hell pounding your chest with
your Bible because you know that the
Pope is the Antichrist.
My goodness, man. It's like Paul says
anyone preaching a false gospel is under
a curse from God. Again, a plain thus
sayeth the Lord. Not esqueological
prophecy that has to, you know, utilize
a bunch of interpretation of symbols and
signs and numbers. No, plain didactic
passages. Crystal clear. He actually
twice cursed because he actually repeats
himself again immediately after saying
it. Anyone preaching a false gospel is
cursed by God. No, it's not okay to
remain in an organization that is
preaching a false gospel and is under a
curse from God. No, Adventism is not
Christian. It is a counterfeit. That's
part of why this platform exists, not to
attack the SDA church. No, it's to reach
people who are deceived, who are
marching toward predition, thinking
everything's okay. It's a big kumbaya
around the fire. Again, I grew up in
Adventism. This was not happening. It
takes guts to do this. You think this
has made me a bunch of friends? You
think it's enjoyable to to every day be
told I'm a tool of Satan and all these
sorts of things SDA say and I'm just
doing this because I'm just trying to
attack the SDA church. No, I like
Adventist.
I literally care about Adventists.
That's why I'm doing this. And sometimes
you need tough love.
And you included, sir, you're supposed
to be an Adventist pastor. You're going
to have a harsher judgment.
and you're marching toward predition,
not even aware of these sources, clearly
evidencing you haven't even researched
this stuff.
Adventism is an inverted mess of
theology, folks. It It is one of Satan's
craftiest deceptions that is splitting
hell wide open. It has people totally
lulled to sleep, dead in their sins and
trespasses with a spirit that's not
resurrected because they don't think
that that needs to happen. But man, they
know the Pope's the Antichrist and they
have all this special insight into
prophecy in the future. Yeah, that's not
going to matter when when
um he did make an argument also about
the idea that we believe in the mark of
the beast
on Sunday will be the mark [music] of
the beast.
Those jokes never hates for me. Anyway,
let's keep going.
[music]
Paul plainly says in Ephesians 1:13,
yeah, actually uh the enforcement of
Sunday will be the mark of the beast.
Now, you can say it is the beast mark
now, but it's not enforced. Nobody can
receive that. Not until it becomes law.
[music] And the Bible does say in
actually in Revelation 13, if I can open
the Bible for this one. So, uh
Revelation 13
verse 8. Uh let's go to down to
verse 15 might be a good one. Yeah,
verse 15. [music] And he had power to
give life to the image of the beast that
the image of the beast should both speak
and cause. So the he that he's talking
about here is the beast of revelation.
Verse 11, which is the lambike beast,
which is the United States of America.
Two horns like a lamb. Um Protestantism
[music] and
uh and republicanism.
So you have a church without a king and
a church uh a nation without a church
without a pope and a nation without a
king. So and there's no crowns as well
establishing the fact we live in a
constitutional republic. So there are
different reasons why you can easily
debunk this. And also in my study of the
rise of the lamblike beast which is the
United States I went in extreme length
breaking it down and I will leave a link
in the description below to the mark of
the beast series so you can check it out
yourself. So he had power to give light
to the image of the beast that the image
of the beast was speaking cause. Look at
this the word cause here when you study
what that actually means. If I can open
a trunk concordance um
it has something to do with enforcing or
making or legislate something. Um this
is kind of where the idea came from.
[music] So here it is right there.
Strong concordance. Let me see if you
can see this on my screen. I don't want
to be labeled a point here. So, the word
cause here, bend together, cause,
commit, content, continue. I hope I'm
getting the right stuff because there's
a lot of little numbers here. Anyway, um
it's like folks, I'm yawning because
it's just like again, James, we've heard
all these assertions 5 million times.
You're just asserting this. Did you
notice that Ephesians 1:13 literally
pops up on the screen that says the Holy
Spirit is the seal? He just completely
ignores it.
And here he is doing these wild
inferences from Revelation that, well,
they have the stamp of approval from God
on the interpretation, so it's talking
about America and the Pope. And oh, but
the Holy Spirit isn't the seal, though.
No, no, no. The the Bible doesn't say
that.
James, all you did was make all the
standard SDA assertion talking points.
the lamblike beast is the United States
of America. And
it's like, "No, dude. This is your
guys's interpretation."
And Ellen White supposedly gave the
stamp of approval, so you think it's
correct, but no. The text does not say
this. You guys think that's what's being
talked about, but literally nothing you
showed, nothing that you showed said
that the mark of the beast will be a
national turned international Sunday law
forcing the entire world to worship on
Sunday. Nothing. Nothing. This is
pathetic. This is pathetic. Don't tell
me that this is deep Bible study and you
literally went to a concordance and read
a word. So now you're gonna utilize
Miller's
uh interpretive principles. It's just
like wow. Wow. I I know all these
assertions, James. It's why I keep
saying I really wish you guys would do
more than just parrot out all the
standard talking points, but you can't
because that's all Adventism has a
script.
I already know the script, bud. I'm a
former Adventist. I I've heard
everything you've said so far, every
single proof text five million times.
It's like appealing to Strong's
concordance is not how Greek works. Like
now you're a Greek grimarian because you
can whip out a concordance.
No. No. This again is just William
Miller's method of interpretation that
SDAs have adopted and borrowed and then
utilized thinking that they're these
biblical wizards when it's like no dude.
That's that's not how the Greek works.
That is not how this works, my friend.
Yeah, that's that's correct. Anyway, it
it is it goes with the idea of
legislating
a particular law. And when you actually
study in Daniel chapter 7, there was a
law that was changed in God's law, which
is the 7th day Sabbath. [music] Um, and
the seven adventist church has a mission
to repair the breach that has been done
to the law of God. So
again, going back to
uh this man,
no, the Sabbath was not changed by the
Pope again for the 10 millionth time.
We've already addressed this I don't
know how many times when Adventists
point to statements where Rome claims to
have done this. Rome is not saying the
Pope changed the Sabbath. Adventists
cite these statements like the Catholic
mere having no clue what they're even
citing from.
They'll say, "See, they even admit it."
And then they read into it. They're
admitting the Pope changed the Sabbath.
No, these are all postreformation
statements. And by church, they mean the
apostles because they believe the
apostles were the first Roman Catholics.
All Christians, all Christians recognize
the first day of corporate worship is
apostolic in origin.
The argument is how does one connect
back to the apostles to then have basis
for such a practice which is why all of
the statements that Adventists point to
are said in the context of apostolic
succession or sometimes they're in
response to the reformed doctrine. So
the reformed branch of the reformation,
the reformed doctrine of the regulative
principle of worship, which I uphold,
which states that worship should only
include that which is clearly prescribed
in scripture. Rome then responds to this
by saying, "Well, Sunday isn't
explicitly prescribed, so therefore you
have no basis for that." To which the
reformed respond by saying, "No, just
like the Westminster confession says,
we're not saying something has to be
verbatim stated, but some things are
taught in scripture by good and
necessary deduction." To which numerous
exogetical arguments are then given to
show this for the first day. The point
being it has nothing to do with the pope
changing God's law like the SDA church
erently asserts because again Ellen
White said it was shown it in vision
according to the book early writings and
that apparently means that God said so
too. James we've responded to John
Lomckang who used the exact same
language that you just did the repairing
of the breach of the Sabbath making
mince meat out of first kings 18 to do
so. Please go and listen more my friend.
Please, please. It is so exhausting
listening to these same silly claims
like over and over and over thinking
that this is some incredible reputation
again of all the videos you choose. You
pick like the most milktoast basic ice
breaker video. He's not really saying
anything new that I haven't already
heard. Uh these are the same old
argument and the argument that
Romans chapter he made reference to
Romans chapter 13 chapter 14 uh verse 5
in reference to the Sabbath. Romans 14:5
is not about [music] the Sabbath. That
is that is a massive misconception.
He say such a thing if going to church
on Saturday was the seal of God. They
believe
he wasn't talking about which day to go
to church. He was talking about uh
stronger brethren and weaker brethren,
fasting days and feasting days because
of eating habits that they were dealing
with. So they had to put certain days in
place to assist them with changing
certain things that they were dealing
with when it comes to food. It had
nothing to do with the Sabbath. As a
matter of fact, the book of Romans makes
zero mention of the day Sabbath, the
seventh day Sabbath. You can type
Sabbath. You will not find it anywhere
in the book of Romans. Um so Romans
chapter 14 has nothing to do with the
seventh day Sabbath. So, I don't know
how he made that application. That is a
massive leap here. Theological leap. It
doesn't have to be this way. [music]
Anyway, um
my the irony
that I mean,
I'm not saying anything new that he
hasn't heard yet. You're utilizing a
short icebreaker video and none of my
actual exogetical articles or videos
where I make in-depth arguments. I
guarantee you. I guarantee you. This guy
doesn't even know my position on the
Sabbath. I guarantee it. I guarantee
this man does not know my position on
the law of God. Guarantee it. Guarantee
it. This is why the SDA church is going
to be in trouble, folks.
We've talked about this with Jud Lake
and Christopher Cernaki. I I mean yet
again
it just they make the assumption that
all former Adventists are the same. They
make all the same arguments when we
don't.
And lots of former SDAs have been
redpilled on my arguments. Well, they're
now former SDAs
have been redpilled on my arguments for
the first day Sabbath and have told me
I'd never even heard this before and it
blew my mind. Right, James? I didn't
cite Romans 14 for the reason that you
assumed. Remember what the point was,
folks. That the Sabbath is the seal of
God. Not is the Sabbath still binding.
Not is the Sabbath perpetual or not.
He's heard all my arguments before, but
he doesn't even understand that I'm a
sabotarian.
Again, this was a short icebreaker
video, not an exogetical one. And I
cited Romans 14 to simply say that if
Paul believed the Sabbath was the seal
of God,
why would he make statements like in
Romans 14, which could easily be
misconstrued?
He should have clarified. He should have
gone to great lengths to make sure
people knew that the seventh day Sabbath
is the seal.
That was the point which you even played
back and I clearly said
I don't know what else to tell you. A
former Adventist is attacking an
Adventist. Nothing new under the sun.
Did he make any argument that I think
was solid? Not really. Some of the same
things he said or the same things I've
heard a lot of people say. Um but a
person can choose to do whatever they
want. And I from my examination of the
man, if I were to look at the man right
and critically ex just look at the
attitude and the approach, the style,
there there is something spiritually
wrong here. There is
some type of spiritual brokenness going
on.
So a lot of what you are hearing or
seeing in the videos that you're
watching
um that is solely dedicated to go after
the Adventist church
that that is the result
of some level of brokenness in the life.
So don't let this face fool you. This is
a face of a man who is in a very bad
place spiritually. This is a person in
need of desperate prayer. Um I don't
think debating this man is good for him.
You will only strengthen his conviction.
You pray for him and you do what Jesus
also told us, right? Uh leave them
alone. They are blind leaders of the
blind and the both shall fall into the
ditch.
And this is why Jesus taught to not
judge based on appearances, folks.
Something Adventists constantly violate.
No, James, that's the face of a man who
had a newborn and was just learning
about lighting techniques and had very
little sleep. Hence why the video was
also very simple.
So, you want to talk about the teachings
of Jesus? My goodness, man. Learn to not
judge based on appearances, Adventists.
Gosh, it's like their favorite thing to
do is judge people based on appearances.
Apparently, Adventists have this special
spiritual gift that no one else has
where they can read people's hearts. But
this is exactly it, folks. people like
this
that that will claim I have a spiritual
issue and a spiritual problem when
they're actually spiritually dead
because they don't even understand the
new birth, but they can aduce from a
six-inute video that I'm spiritually
broken and I have something wrong with
me. [laughter]
No, it's like when the facts are I'm
actually on fire for the Lord Jesus
Christ. I do or have in the past done
all sorts of other evangelistic efforts
uh to all sorts of people. I'm not just
an apologist to Seventh Day Adventists.
I love the truth. I care about
Adventists and I want to warn them about
the deception of Adventism. Hence why I
get very passionate about this because
when you know the truth and you can see
that people are deceived and they're
walking toward the fire, it's not the
person that gets worked up saying
there's a fire. Yo, there's a fire. It's
not that person who's spiritually dead
or spiritually broken or attacking, etc.
It's that person who actually cares
about people. Furthermore, I'm a member
in a local church under qualified
pastors and elders with accountability.
Anyone that knows me personally, many of
whom watch this channel and are not
SDAs, never have been, they heard this
guy, they also laughed because they know
this isn't true. I'm not always like
this 247, but man, they can aduce all
this from a six-inute video. Don't even
engage them. Don't even engage. You
know, he's got that soft piano music
playing in the background.
Again, Adventists, heed Jesus's words
and stop judging based on appearances.
You hypocrites. You claim to be staunch
commandmentkeepers that obey God better
than anyone else, yet you don't even
follow Jesus's most basic commands. It's
like, James, you know nothing about me,
sir. Nothing. And in sheer irony, we
pray for you. You're supposed to be a
pastor. You're going to have a stricter
judgment.
You're blind leading the blind, not me.
I'm sounding the alarm. I'm not a
teacher. I'm not a leader. I'm not a
pastor.
I'm sharing information. Again, had you
done any amount of digging into this
platform, why it was started? This is
all public information.
I'm here sharing information to get
people caught up to speed.
I'm not a I'm not a pastor. I'm not
qualified for that. I've had people ask
me before, "Why haven't you gone to
seminary? You seem like you'd be good at
preaching." I'm not qualified. I terror
I The thought of that sends terror down
my spine. There's going to be a harsher
judgment. You're the blind leading the
blind, not me.
I'm a Christian that felt called and
equipped to reach Adventists with the
truth, which is exactly what's
happening. And we praise God for it. And
there's not a single thing that you guys
can do to stop it. You claim I didn't
present anything new. You've heard it
all. Yet, as we saw, you apparently
haven't because you didn't even know the
multiple sources that state Ellen White
is the infallible interpreter.
And that says it all really. But this
silly don't engage with people like
this. We've heard it all before.
Stickick. No, it's not going to work. I
mean, by all means, keep doing that. But
anyone that actually listens like you
should have done. They're going to see
how silly this response was and how you
didn't even bother to do an iod of
research before making this video. I've
watched a decent amount of you, sir,
which is why I know your name. I've
heard your sermons, etc. I don't just
pop off on a video um you know,
responding to a person after watching
six minutes. I do lots of listening and
research on the people that I respond
to. You know, Adventists came at me, you
shouldn't call Doug Bachelor a liar.
Yeah. And I'll give account for that.
But I didn't just pop off the cuff and
make that claim. I've listened to
hundreds of hours of that guy in in
particular for years and years and
years. So when I said about specific
things, very specific claims that he
made, I know that he is lying. I'm not
just assuming. I'm not just inferring. I
knew that he was lying. Not saying he's
being malicious, but the point being,
you need to do some better research,
bud. You need to do a lot better
research than this. But like I said, by
all means, keep this defense up. We're
going to keep doing what we're doing and
watch God move in a mighty way and watch
thousands and thousands of Adventists
come to know the truth. Hopefully
eventually millions.
Holy apostate. Did he say that?
Come on, man.
[music]